[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días entradas 24 este es un
magacín informativo 100% dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre es liviana
valencia aquí damos una mirada en
profundidad a los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
al menos 13 personas han muerto en las
protestas desatadas por la muerte del
presidente de chad idriss deby que tiene
el país un vídeo en una nueva crisis
miles de ciudadanos se han tomado las
calles de las principales ciudades desde
donde protestan por la creación del
consejo militar de transición decidido
por el hijo del fallecido mandatario
por un repatriado los cuerpos de los dos
periodistas españoles y el ciudadano
irlandés que murieron asesinados en
burkina faso según las autoridades
locales un grupo armado atacó un convoy
militar en una zona de reserva natural
en la frontera entre este país y benin y
las investigaciones en la zona continúa
y las directivas de la universidad de
ciudad del cabo en sudáfrica evaluar los
daños dejados por el incendio forestal
que afectó a la biblioteca del centro
educativo donde reposaban documentos
históricos y fílmicos de gran valor
patrimonial ciudadanos voluntarios
ayudan en las tareas de recuperación
tenemos reportes con nuestro
corresponsal
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días y empezamos en
chats donde al menos 13 personas han
perdido la vida 10 de ellas en llamen a
la capital en las protestas y desmanes
protagonizados por parte de la
ciudadanía en contra del gobierno de
transición instaurado tras la muerte
inesperada del presidente idriss deby el
pasado 19 de abril
la oposición ha convocado a
manifestaciones en contra del consejo
militar de transición en cabeza del hijo
del fallecido presidente mamá idriss
deby de 37 años los habitantes de yamena
huyen hacia otros destinos en medio de
la incertidumbre por el brote de
violencia
la cita de muertos podría seguir
aumentando debido a los enfrentamientos
entre civiles y autoridades
los habitantes de la capital chadiana
abandonan la ciudad muchos están
preocupados por lo que pueda suceder en
el país luego de que el presidente
idriss deby fuera asesinado
inesperadamente
lo que esperamos es el momento de la
transición no queremos otro
representante militar en el poder
durante esta transición porque habrá
problemas nuevamente se necesita a un
civil
son muchos en chad los que no quieren al
nuevo consejo militar en el poder sin
embargo los representantes del ejército
aseguraron que no será para siempre
las fuerzas de defensa y de seguridad no
buscan tomar el poder
me gustaría asegurarle a la gente que
los miembros del consejo militar
devolverán el poder a un gobierno civil
a través de elecciones libres y
democráticas en un plazo de 18 meses
del mismo - el hijo del mandatario
fallecido mahamat idriss deby dirigirá
el consejo militar de transición y no el
presidente del parlamento como dicta la
constitución ante el panorama que se
avecina eeuu anunció que su embajada en
chad seguirá elaborando pero permanece
bajo el estado de salida ordenada por
las preocupaciones de seguridad en el
país
guaguas lo que queremos ver es una
transición que sea consistente con la
constitución de chad las instituciones
de chat están consagradas en su carta
magna pero queremos que los elementos de
esa constitución estén protegidos en el
futuro ya sea que eso implique una
transición del poder mientras los países
de occidente perdieron a un importante
aliado en la lucha contra el yihadismo
al norte de áfrica las autoridades
chadianas decretaron un toque de queda
nocturno y el cierre de todas las
fronteras
los cuerpos de los dos periodistas
españoles y el activista medioambiental
irlandés que fueron asesinados el pasado
27 de abril en burkina faso llegaron a
territorio europeo en un comunicado
conjunto españa alemania francia e
italia indicaron que continuarán
trabajando de la mano de las autoridades
africanas en el sahel para frenar el
actuar de los grupos terroristas también
avanzan las investigaciones para
establecer el hecho en el que los
comunicadores fallecieron cuando
grababan un documental sobre medio
ambiente
así fueron recibidos los restos de los
dos periodistas españoles y el
conservacionista irlandés que fueron
asesinados en burkina faso los cuerpos
llegaron a la base aérea de torrejón de
ardoz donde los esperaba la ministra de
exteriores de españa y una
representación diplomática de irlanda
davis y el roberto que tanto han hecho
tanto han hecho por dar voz a los que no
la tienen tanto han hecho para
esclarecer realidades que nos rodean y
que a veces son invisibles y con ello
tanto han hecho por dar a nuestra
democracia la fuerza que necesita los
periodistas españoles fueron
identificados como david beriáin de 44
años y roberto fraile de 47 quienes
rodeaban un documental sobre la caza
furtiva junto con el conservacionista
irlandés rory young cofundador de la ong
ecologísta cheng eta wildlife los
extranjeros viajaban con efectivos de
las fuerzas armadas en el oriente del
país cuando el convoy en el que se
desplazaban fue atacado por un grupo
armado los tres extranjeros y un
burkinés fueron asesinados en la
emboscada en un comunicado conjunto
españa francia alemania e italia
condenaron los asesinatos y reiteraron
su compromiso con el sahel la lucha
contra el terrorismo los tráficos
ilícitos y todas las formas de violencia
constituyen un objetivo esencial para
garantizar el estado de derecho y la
coexistencia pacífica de los angelinos
el gobierno de burkina faso señaló que
ningún grupo armado ha reclamado la
autoría del ataque pero medios españoles
aseguraron que se trataría de una
organización relacionada con al qaeda
pasamos ahora a temas de salud porque
una candidata vacuna contra la malaria
ha demostrado una eficacia sin igual del
77 por ciento en ensayos en burkina faso
así lo anunció la universidad de oxford
que desarrolla este medicamento esto la
convertiría en la primera vacuna contra
la malaria o paludismo en alcanzar el
objetivo de eficacia del 75 por ciento
establecido por organización mundial de
la salud
un gran avance en la lucha contra la
malaria investigadores de la universidad
de oxford aseguran que están trabajando
en una vacuna con una efectividad del 77
por ciento contra la enfermedad
parasitaria
el 77 por ciento es el nivel más alto de
protección jamás alcanzado podría
fortalecer la acción de las herramientas
existentes para controlar la malaria
mosquiteros insecticidas y medicamentos
para los niños son el estudio realizado
durante un año en 450 niños de burkina
faso no mostró efectos secundarios
graves un ensayo de fase final en casi
5000 niños ahora debe confirmar la
eficacia de la vacuna antes de ser
aprobado por la oms y las autoridades
sanitarias nacionales un procedimiento
que aún podría llevar años pero que los
investigadores de oxford esperan incluso
acelerar tomando el ejemplo reciente del
cobi 19
y los reguladores africanos pudieran
aprobar una vacuna contra el cob y 19 en
menos de un año no sería apropiado
acelerar el proceso para una vacuna
contra la malaria no lo sabemos todavía
el debate está en curso en sí y
transmitida por mosquitos la malaria es
una enfermedad que mata a más de 400.000
personas al año y es una de las
principales causas de mortalidad
infantil en áfrica en 2020 este parásito
mató a 4 veces más personas que el cob y
19 en todo el continente africano y los
tratamientos que existen hoy en día a
menudo son demasiado caros e
inaccesibles para quienes más lo
necesitan
el presidente de somalia abdullahi
mohamed farmajo se vio a la presión de
la oposición y la comunidad
internacional y anunció que rechaza
extender por dos años su mandato como lo
había anunciado en días anteriores su
período presidencial venció el pasado 8
de febrero el mandatario también instó a
las fuerzas militares y cuerpos de
seguridad del estado a mantener la
estabilidad en la capital somalí
mogadiscio y también la seguridad de la
población civil farmajo que dirige el
país desde 2017 llama a la celebración
de nuevas elecciones en señal de
reconciliación y aseguró que buscará el
respaldo del parlamento para el nuevo
proceso electoral
la valor era francesa total confirmó que
la situación de inseguridad en el norte
de mozambique causada por milicias
yihadistas ha llevado a la multinacional
a retirar todo su personal y poner fin
al mega proyecto de extracción de gas en
la región a finales de marzo el
principal grupo islamista del país se
tomó la ciudad de la palma a pocos
kilómetros del proyecto de total
generando una grave crisis humanitaria
en la región veamos
por causa de fuerza mayor el grupo
energético francés total declaró la
retirada de su gran proyecto gasístico
en el norte de mozambique debido a la
inseguridad derivada de los últimos
ataques de aristas
considerando la evolución de la
situación de seguridad en el norte de
mozambique total confirme el retiro de
todo el personal del sitio tea funk y
esta situación lleva a total como
operador del proyecto gn l de mozambique
a declarar fuerza mayor una situación
previsible a principios de marzo la
compañía petrolera había paralizado sus
operaciones en la provincia de cabo
delgado luego de que el grupo islamista
al-shabab tomara la ciudad de palma a
finales de marzo a pocos kilómetros del
mega proyecto gasístico las
consecuencias de su partida serán
visibles en la economía mozambiqueña ya
que el gobierno esperaba recaudar
millones de dólares para transformar el
país
mozambique está sumido en una grave
crisis humanitaria aprobada con los
recientes ataques y hadise estás que
dejan más de 20.000 personas desplazadas
y cientos de fallecidos en el último mes
de guascor dejen atrás los atroces
ataques en la ciudad de palma las
familias y las personas han tenido que
abandonar sus pertenencias y medios de
vida y huir en busca de seguridad
muchos se han dispersado por los
distritos de siguiente pueda pemba y
monte pues así como por las pequeñas
islas que salpican la costa de cabo
delgado lo que suma unas
ya desesperada en el norte de mozambique
la violencia de la insurgencia islamista
en el norte de mozambique inició en 2017
desde entonces más de 950 mil
desplazados necesitan asistencia vital
urgente miles de personas se enfrentan a
una hambruna civera hablamos ahora del
voraz incendio en el parque nacional de
table mountain en sudáfrica que estudió
parcialmente la biblioteca de la
universidad de ciudad del cabo y miles
de documentos películas y obras de arte
de gran importancia patrimonial para el
país austral
ahora las directivas de la universidad
intenta determinar la magnitud de las
pérdidas tanto a nivel material como
intelectual ciudadanos voluntarios y
también personal especializado de la
universidad trabajan para recuperar todo
el material posible debido a su
importancia histórica desde ciudad del
cabo no reportó nuestro corresponsal en
sudáfrica salam fayad
un incendio forestal ha alcanzado las
instalaciones de la biblioteca de la
universidad de ciudad del cabo y aunque
estos incendios son frecuentes en esta
ciudad y en las laderas de las montañas
que la rodean y nunca habían afectado de
manera significativa a la universidad
que se encuentra en las laderas de la
emblemática table mountain y una de las
instalaciones más afectadas fue la sala
de lectura jagger que es donde nos
encontramos en este momento donde se
perdió una colección de manuscritos del
áfrica subshariana que contaba con unos
70 mil títulos también aquí se
encontraba el archivo fílmico africano
que contaba con las tres de 3500
películas que se han perdido de manera
irremediable también hay documentos que
consultaba con frecuencia el gobierno
sudafricano y había parte de manuscritos
que estaban siendo digitalizados y si
bien parte de ellos alcanzaron a entrar
en la esfera digital una buena parte de
ellos también se perdió con las llamas
se calcula también que podría haber
daños residuales después del incendio y
después de los esfuerzos de los bomberos
por apagar las llamas de manera que en
grupos enteros de voluntarios se han
organizado de manera independiente para
rescatar todo lo que sea posible de este
archivo histórico que se encuentra en
los sótanos de ese edificio
y finalizamos con música aquí en áfrica
siete días y con el artista congoleño
bien conocido como de congo boy quien
presentó su nueva canción titulada make
la pegajosa coreografía del videoclip se
ha hecho girar en las redes sociales
donde cientos de personas han
participado en el mail challenge esta
forma parte de una invitación a bailar
el ritmo del en bombo lo característico
de la república democrática del congo y
también de congo brazzaville y también
se les llama se ven en esta deriva de la
rumba congoleña y el supuso
así finalizamos en áfrica siete días
pero ustedes pueden continuar con más en
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
para ampliar la información de américa
latina y el mundo quédense con nosotros
esto es france24
como mencioné
tú
[Música]